[Music]
Circle Circle dot dot you just got the
cootie shot that was a day my friend
Amanda saved me in the first grade
because by giving me this cootie shot
which is just like a simple vaccination
she effectively made me immune to a
crazy disease called the cooties which
for those of you who don't know is this
highly contagious and infectious disease
that's transmitted by little boys and
girls when they talk to each other in
elementary school so for a
seven-year-old Mexican girl who had just
arrived to the u.s. it kind of took me
some time to understand why the girls in
my class that I had gotten the cooties
to begin with see every day during lunch
I did something outrageous because I
would go out into the playground with my
lunchbox and I would just talk to my
best friend Alonso Alonso sorry Zeke and
that somehow required this vaccination
that cootie shot stuck with me literally
until today fast forward a couple of
decades and Here I am at Stanford
excited to talk about gender equality
issues a subject I care deeply about
since that pretty traumatizing day at
the playground except every time we talk
about gender equality issues everything
from gender biases equal pay gender role
expectations women in the workplace
all I see around me is for the most part
women women participants and women
panelists discussing what it means to be
a woman and when we do engage with men
in these conversations perhaps in
classrooms like this one or forums or
dinners I kind of get a sense that the
air starts to become a little bit
thicker that the tension rises and that
the conversations don't seem to move
forward and that brings me to the
subject of today's low-key note small
conversations can create big changes
I'll walk you through three things today
first so what goes on when we have these
conversations between men and women that
makes things so difficult
second why does it matter to have these
conversations anyways I'm sorry what can
we do to make things better so on the
first point what goes on when we engage
in these conversations that makes things
so difficult to explore that I surveyed
135 men and 131 women at the GSP that's
more than one out of every four of you
anonymously and had coffee chats with
over 30 men over the past month where I
simply asked you what do you think and
how do you feel when we engage in these
conversations with the GSB and what I
found was quite unsettling I'll start
first with what I found out about the
men see the men they're not feeling
great in these conversations more than
70% of men describe their feelings as
frustrated and not excited more than a
third said their first reaction when
they found themselves in these
conversations was oh no one of them
changed the multiple choice option and
said my first reaction is to find the
nearest exit and see that might be
because men are feeling judged men said
things like I'm feeling guilty for just
showing up as a man in these
conversations it's a little loose for me
so easy to mess it up I just rather not
say anything if I make the slightest
mistake I'll be vilified regardless of
what I say women still get offended the
downside is pretty high the upside not
clear so not surprisingly 81% of men
said they tend to participate less when
talking about gender equality than any
other issue at the GSB but see despite
not feeling great and feeling judged men
are supportive ninety-six percent of men
said the gender equality issues are
important to them and that they should
be discussed many of them quoted their
wives or sisters their daughters their
partners saying things like I love my
wife
but that doesn't give me a say in these
conversations while I'm wildly
supportive there's something insincere
about my opinion I'm a strong supporter
of gender equality but I find myself in
the way of gender equality so the
frustration comes it seems from a place
of being easily misunderstood not from a
place of not caring so what did I find
out
about the women see the women are also
not feeling great in these conversations
more than 75% of women describe their
feelings as frustrated too and defensive
and their frustration comes from
different reasons in the men it's
because these conversations don't move
quickly we stay on the same safe and
superficial topics it's hard to get my
point across the men don't get it and
women make it very personal the majority
of women described a big incentive to
participate saying things like the
majority of women described a big
incentive to participate saying things
like I have to go out there and defend
my gender I'm carrying the torch I'm
paving the road and see I can speak for
myself and saying that it's there's so
much in my mind about these topics that
it is very easy to get very emotional
and charged up about it as I just did
now so zooming out from what I found out
about the survey about the men and the
women this kind of reminded me of the
game of hide-and-seek see to me the
women are playing seekers it's our
territory we're on the lookout looking
for any small mistake and the men are
kind of playing hiding they feel a lil
incentive to participate they're kind of
waiting for the game to be over and they
can find the nearest exit but the
problem with this dynamic is that we've
missed each other in these conversations
we've missed the opportunity to build
something of value to innovate to share
personal stories to actually hear what
the other person has to say small
conversations can create big changes so
now to my second point why does it
matter that we can have good
conversations anyways for inspiration
for that I went to a place very far
removed from the GSB growing up I
visited an indigenous community in the
northern mountains of Mexico where
gender equality issues are pretty real
and for years in this community the
little girls didn't have access to
schools because there were only enough
teachers to educate the little boys but
you see all of the teachers were women
so these women teachers gathered
together and door by door and family by
family had the smallest of conversations
with these families to explain that if
they didn't educate the little girls
there wouldn't be any teachers for the
little boys or girls of generations to
come and the point of the story is that
it was because of having these small
conversations and stepping into the
homes of these families that they were
able to create bigger changes that
reminds me of the story of one of the
men I served
ESP who talked to me about his mom who
had been abandoned by her husband and
had to quit school at a very young age
and worked tirelessly her entire life to
get her son to Stanford and he said the
most productive conversations I have
about gender equality issues at the GSB
are when I Skype with my mom on the
weekends so not in these classrooms and
that really got to me see because the
point about being good at these
conversations isn't to talk about me and
my extremely privileged position as a
woman at the GSB but rather to give a
space and voice to talk about the
millions of women who can't even dream
of the possibility of being at the GSB
let alone have nine minutes to talk to
you about talking about it so now to my
third point what can we do to make
things better my gift to you today is
the following Circle Circle dot dot you
just got a cootie shot you see a man who
never told me that the cooties requires
a revaccination in grad school and the
point of that is that we should feel
free to go out there and have
conversations that make us feel excited
engaged and not frustrated and that
requires a lot of intentionality on both
the men and the women
it requires suspending judgment making
mistakes allowing the other to make
mistakes see over the past month I've
learned more about gender equality by
talking to men and asking men than I
ever learned in any woman only event and
I realize that as a person that gets
very emotional and takes this topic very
personally I have an important choice to
make about how I approach men in these
conversations I can choose to get easily
offended or I can choose to get easily
curious I choose to get easily curious
so I want you to pick a person from the
opposite gender in this room I pick
Alonzo and invite that person for a
15-minute coffee chat about gender
equality and if you don't have a
specific topic in mind you can talk
about your reactions to this so keynote
and the challenge here is for the men
ask the uncomfortable question and feel
free to say what you actually think and
to the women ask them what they think
and how they feel and be prepared to get
curious and maybe instead of playing a
game of hide-and-seek we can play a game
of puzzles where we put the pieces
together bit by bit because I do think
that it's in these small conversations
between the little boy
girls in that playground in elementary
school and between the young men and
women here now at the GSB where we'll
find the answers to those bigger
questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]